[Music]
u.s president joe biden has urged the
country to use show unity while honoring
the victims of the 9 11 attacks it's
been 20 years since hijacked passenger
planes were flown into the world trade
center in new york and the pentagon just
outside washington dc three thousand
people were killed rob reynolds looks
back at the aftermath of those events
a whisper in the president's ear set in
motion actions that changed the u.s and
the world
three days after the attacks president
george bush stood atop the rubble of
lower manhattan and promised retribution
i can hear you the rest of the world
hears you
and the people
[Applause]
and the people who knock these buildings
down
will hear all of us soon
blame immediately fell on osama bin
laden's al qaeda organization based in
afghanistan which had already carried
out several deadly attacks on u.s
targets abroad less than a month after
the attacks the u.s began military
action in afghanistan bin laden escaped
but was tracked down in pakistan nearly
a decade later the united states has
conducted an operation that killed osama
bin laden the leader of al qaeda
but even with bin laden dead the war in
afghanistan dragged on for another 10
years ending in a taliban victory the
september 11 attacks were a profound
shock with images playing out on tv
in the aftermath lawmakers rushed to
overhaul national security laws with
little or no debate
the events of 9 11 really frightened
people enough that i don't think many
people ever read the patriot act and
realized
really how profoundly it changed what
government is able to do
in terms of tracking and conducting
surveillance on american citizens
for many americans the closest contact
with the new enhanced security state
came at the airport the magnetometer the
metal detector the x-ray machines
you had to start
having your id scrutinized
and then taking off your shoes the
limitations on liquids and then finally
in 2010 the full body scanner things
that few americans would have
contemplated before now were widely
accepted the government initially was
intercepting virtually all of the
metadata on all of our emails and
telephone conversations without any
warrants this was just dragnet
surveillance
the invasion of iraq in 2003 overthrew
saddam hussein who was later captured
and executed but it produced no weapons
of mass destruction
two hundred thousand iraqis and more
than four thousand u.s troops were
killed the naval base at guantanamo bay
cuba became a prison where so-called
enemy combatants were held indefinitely
some remain there to this day
a color-coded system of threats was
introduced keeping citizens on edge that
was the goal frighten the american
people you know inflate the risk factor
a million fold and then people say oh
well we have to accept this because
otherwise there'll be bodies on the
sidewalks and on the streets and
everywhere else the abuse of detainees
by u.s soldiers at abu ghraib prison in
iraq appalled many in the u.s and around
the globe
but at the same time in the u.s
veneration of the military grew we have
sort of fetishized the military over the
last 20 years we have no idea of the
long-term impact
of having people who've grown up
entirely during a war period or people
whose entire adult life has been serving
in a war zone
four presidents and two wars later the
u.s is a far different country from the
one that existed 20 years ago
rob reynolds al jazeera
memorial services will be held across
the u.s to mark the 9 11 attacks emily
anguin looks back at how that day
unfolded 20 years ago
it began as a clear sunny tuesday
morning along america's east coast just
before 8 o'clock on september 11 2001
american airlines flight 11 takes off
from boston followed by united airlines
flight 175.
a short while later american airlines
flight 77 departs from washington's
dulles airport and united airlines
flight 93 from newark new jersey
at 8 46 a.m flight 11 crashes into the
north tower of the world trade center in
new york people assume it's a terrible
accident more than a thousand first
responders head to the scene
17 minutes later flight 175
crashes into the south tower president
bush is informed that america is under
attack american airlines flight 77 then
crashes into the pentagon authorities
ground all flights across the united
states but one more plane was still in
the air united 93 was headed for
washington dc possibly the white house
capitol building or other targets after
burning for 56 minutes the south tower
of the world trade center collapses
morning networks are showing these
pictures live to millions of americans
the passengers and crew on united 93
overpower the hijackers and the plane
crashes into a field in shanksville
pennsylvania
at 10 28 am the north tower of the world
trade center also collapses nearly 3 000
people were killed including citizens
from more than 90 countries